This season grab 'em by the tinsel with the
official White House 2020 Christmas Ornament.
The largest, classiest, most beautiful ornament evercreated.
And it comes with a synthetic epoxy so it really sticks to that tree.
Don't worry you can get it loose, it just takes a while and damages the tree in the process.
While you're at it,why not pick up some ornaments from previousadministrations?
Like this delightful ObamaOrnament, the most transparent in history.
We've got plenty of administration ornaments tochoose from.
Buy two and we'll send you a Thomas Jefferson Ancestry.com gift card.
Buy five and you'll receive a festive Waco Compound yule log.
Did you know we require other governmentagencies to make ornaments?
How else would ornaments get made?
Get the latest fabulous designs from the NSA, the TSA, the IRS, the Department of Education,
even the New York Department of Corrections.
This year the ornamentabsolutely unquestionably hangs itself.
Congresscan't agree on a new one so they've been issuingthe same continuing ordinance since 1997.
And whilethe Small Business Administration is restrictedfrom selling ornaments this year due to COVID,
the FDA ornament should be coming soon, we're just waiting on the approval process.
Might haveit by January, but who knows.
No rush.
Not...not a big deal, take your time. Take your time.
And speaking of January don't forget to tune in for the Federal Government's New Year's Eve Spectacular
whereonce again the CDC will be dropping the ball.
Merry Christmas and happy holidays from the WhiteHouse Commemorative Ornament,
and Fuel Efficiency Standards Commission, a federal sub agency
jointly governed by the White House Visitors Center and the U.S. Fish and Wildlife Service,
inconjunction with the Federal Pension GuaranteeCommittee
White House Christmas Ornaments,
because everything needs to be political.